les machines ne tournent pas il n'y a
plus un seul canard c'est la première
fois que lionel candelon revient sur son
exploitation
depuis que ces animaux sont partis sur
ordre de l'état se faire euthanasier
c'est la gorge nouée par l'émotion qu'il
nous décrit lusage aujourd'hui perdu de
ses bâtiments
ça c'est l'unité un des deux unités de
croissance ou donc il y avait les
canards qui est un qui ont été abattus
et donc vous là c'est pareil depuis
l'abattage des bâtiments sont vides
vides de vivid eu envie de travailler
vide
philippe nous montre le champ où les
canards sont élevés en plein air tout en
marchant il raconte l'épisode douloureux
où il a été obligé de charger ses bêtes
pour les envoyer à l'abattoir
la première phase la plus dure
psychologiquement ça a été de charger
des animaux soi-même vivant dans le
camion qui allait amener à l'abattage
donc l'euthanasie ça a été ça a été une
journée un vraiment éprouvante
psychologiquement
aujourd'hui la situation financière de
lionel est préoccupante peu indemnisées
par l'état y ne peut plus vers cet
salaires depuis plusieurs mois
résultat son compte en banque et dans le
rouge avec plus de 1000 euros
d'endettement pour s'en sortir et la
filme demande pour percevoir le rsa
en attendant des jours meilleurs